i feel like i should say congratulations
is that like the wrong thing to say i
mean no like that that's a nice thing to
say
we're glad to make people happy
we're in show business so we're used to
hearing much worse things so thank you
yeah
um i feel like i kind of want to start a
little bit at the beginning of the
process um
and i'm curious um when it came to kind
of
figuring things out in terms of the song
itself like
did the two of you have
um
did you kind of pitch it to marvel or
was it more that they approached you
with
this is the idea we want
how can you make it happen they they
came to to us mark had met kevin at an
event in uh at the at the academy of uh
awards um
two years ago when we were nominated for
mary poppins and so you know returns but
yes sorry and he uh so mary poppins we
would be 97 years old
so he uh they they
started a sort of a relationship and
then
uh kevin
uh someone had pitched this to kevin and
he and they he he said that's a great
idea and the next thing you know he
thought i have the perfect guys to do it
so that's it all came out
yeah i i do believe that they did
think that it should be at the battle of
new york
yes maybe i should have done some more
research before the interviews to remind
myself but
i don't think there were other scenarios
like and then we chose i think it was
the battle of new york
and that seemed just right for us like
to create like a act one closer you
could definitely imagine the curtain
falling as you know on the end although
the great ending that's there on the tv
show now with the kind of jazz hands
ending um it's just a lot of fun um
and uh scott had the idea of of
starting the song with the idea of save
the city that it's new yorkers imploring
the avengers to come and help
you know cause who else but the avengers
could deal with what was going on and we
were also in the middle of the worst
part of the pandemic when new york was
hit the hardest when we were writing it
so
um that became the idea of someone
please save the city became part of that
that
crime yeah it was it was that time when
you know new yorkers were opening their
windows every night at 7 00 p.m and
banging pots and pans you know to say
thank you to you know all the frontline
workers and uh
i was gonna say i was curious too if if
there had ever been a conversation about
potentially sitting the song somewhere
else in the mcu but you would you mark
answered my question perfectly um you
know i
i'm sure fans would have been curious if
it had been more than one song like
seeing a potential you know first
avengers you know set tune or something
along those lines
right yeah yeah well yeah also but
captain america is a very he's he's got
such a beautiful story because it goes
back to the 40s and things like that so
yeah it could have been a hole
um
what was the process behind getting some
big broadway broadway folks involved
because you know adam's obviously
singing pretty heavily on the track so
was that kind of
was that a little bit more of like a
we're going to sneakily bring people in
you know keep everything under wraps it
was it was really just um
who can sing it yeah i can't sing i was
i found myself writing music that i
can't sing
we wrote
and then one before we continued with
the rest of the song we wanted to make
sure it was the right direction
so
the only person who could do vocal
vocally uh adapt to it was was uh with
adam i mean he came to mind adam
who i didn't i mean i had met him i
think once
really in passing and but like i i
texted our mutual friend seth rudetsky
who had done a whole broadway show with
him i said can you give me adam pascal's
phone number i'm going to text him to
see if and can he
belt a b-flat or a b and hang onto it
and seth was like are you crazy he can
literally hit any note and hang on to it
with or without vibrato whichever you
want so
i texted adam pascal out of the blue and
and said you know it's mark and scott
and they've asked us to write a song
that's basically like
the avengers musical and would you and
before i could even finish the question
he just texted yes
and you know he was at home as everyone
was and you know a lot of singers or
performers at that point had all gotten
their own microphones at home to try to
continue to work as much
as little or as much as was possible at
the time
so adam and then another friend named ty
taylor who i had only just sort of met
those are the first two guys i texted
who the only guys i knew who could
possibly hit all these notes and sing
with that kind of theatrical rock and
roll style
and they sang the whole song and demoed
it and those vocals that they recorded
in their home are are the vocals that
are on the recording even they're even a
little distorted here and there but we
didn't want to kind of like try to
capture
lightning in a bottle twice we so loved
what they had sung
and luckily they got to be in the actual
number and the filming
and there are a lot of other broadway
names who are only the voices of the
avengers because of kovid
uh they couldn't bring a whole bunch of
people you know flying people in was
very you know
they just couldn't do it with everyone
so it's very old-school movie musicals
where the people on screen singing
that's not really their voices i i don't
want to crush anyone's bubble
first anyone's mobile but
it's phenomenal singers like rory
donovan christopher sieber uh derek
klena
yeah shayna steele and bonnie milligan i
mean phenomenal singers every single one
of them
who and we were all so thrilled to be
doing it but we couldn't tell anybody
you know half a year of hanging on to
this so it was so thrilling when they
finally put the song that little bit in
that first trailer and then to see the
reaction of marvel fans
to it was just so
uh
thrilling it was thrilling yeah i got my
favorite compliment i've ever gotten was
somebody wrote it's slaps so i thought
that's better than a raven in new york
times isn't it that's that's the modern
day equivalent i think um
i would love to know the the
uh
thought process behind uh adding ant-man
to the song for the musical because it
was it just purely for the joke of you
know he wasn't even there but we're
going to stick him in anyway kind of
thing
makes clint go wait a second they didn't
get it right so but that was a marvel
request so you know that it's a perfect
example of the sense of humor they have
within the movies
and we also you know scott and i both
knew that i mean that was the main point
in this in the script
was that clint is dragged to the musical
avengers musical and that he is just
rolling his eyes at it going why am i
here and what is this what
this really happened to me and now it's
their singing and dancing and what's
ant-man doing in this you know so that
was all part of the script and we were
more than happy to oblige
uh it's hysterical that guy dancing as a
hand man
i think i have time for one more
question which is are you both prepared
for the possibility uh that this could
become a full musical in real life uh
and if so are you are you ready to come
back and and do the whole thing
yes we are equal to the challenge yes
if only kevin feige was on social media
i'd say
inundate him with requests i mean but a
lot of people are saying it so you know
marvel works in mysterious ways we'll
see what
um those are actually all the questions
i have but thank you so much for taking
the time to sit and chat it was it was a
blast and and the song's great and
honestly i hope i hope we'll get to see
a little more rogers the musical at some
point because it was a lot of fun
thank you thank you